MOBLEY COMESCATCH.
A LOW-SCORING AFFAIR AS
>> GARLAND GETS AROUND BLEDSOE--
>> YOU MAY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT.
HIS  KENNARD, HE
THAT. COLLIN SEXTON COMES AWAY
WITH THE GIVE.
ON PAPER IT IS CANARD.
COLLIN SEXTON HAS BEEN THE RECI
CORNER, NO REBOUND. HALF AND PL1
.
GREAT PASS INSIDE.
RESPECT FOR SEXTON, HIS THIRD
SLAM HERE I
HE FORCES THE DEPTH THAT HE AND.
JACKSON THAT THRIVE AND THE-.
GIVES THE BEAUFORT PAUL.
GEORGE INTO THE PAINTLIKE THIS.
, THE CAVALIERS WITH NINE
THREE-POINTERS  AND THE SITE IS
.
HE LEADS
HE CHISELS HIS ITS WAY TO THE
FREE-THROW LINE. TO HIM
JUST WHEN THE CLIPPERSON BREAK..
DIRECTING TRAFFIC, COMES UP
FIRING.
ANDHE THREE.WILL  SO FOR
TWO WINS LOW.
NOT MUCH OF
PUTS THE DEFENDER IN HIS BACK
POCKET
IN UPTAKE TAKE AWAY FROM ALL TH
FREEBIES.OT HAVE
NUMBERS.
HE JUST WANTED TO MAKE SOMETHIN
OUT OF  AS
MANY AS HIM ON THE
BASEBALL TEAM.OF THE BUS
HAVE TO, QUALITY WINS AGAINST A
PLAYOF
DOES T